[Music]
alright game of the hour oh here we go
haha as a lot of people talking about
mass effect in the chat on YouTube and
twitch for those joining we are gonna
get more into mass effect specifically
but first I want to kind of lean into it
kind of hints at my take on the game I
want to talk about other triple-a games
that kind of had rough launches for one
reason or another and whether or not
they fixed set problems at release and
maybe can Mass Effect learn from them
and or maybe have the same success in
subsequent weeks or months after release
but anyway yeah I mean mass effect is
out we will talk about more specifically
but it's kind of having a rough launch I
mean there's been I think gifts about
its poor performance technically are
kind of being an overblown and they're
really funny but I think they're bigger
problems game than the technical
problems but as it stands now it's kind
of buggy to say the least you just saw
there I think that was John Luke side
key his uh gameplay of Mass Effect
Andromeda he's enjoying this game I
believe from for the most part and he
was talking to drag rack the krogan your
Krogan party character in this game and
another track came out of the Drac he
was talking to start wandering the room
and then afterward he's gonna have to
correct me if I'm wrong but he could I'm
pretty sure he could talk to both of
them and that's not supposed to happen
and then I was talking to Brad over at
Giant Bomb he was saying that he
restarted the game to try something I
don't know it was a different platform
or what but he restarted the game and
when your character wakes up from cryo
sleep tough like right when you get
control there's Krogan raining from the
sky right when you get control your
character a cerrar Scott rider whoever
you choose from cryo sleep you know the
idea being there sent the Andromeda
galaxy have been in cryosleep 600
something years they left right after
the events of mass effect 2 but before
the events of three how many farts built
up in those 600 yeah I know you
rim that's the why the Nexus is failing
because it's built with methane gas but
a character in DC was next to there was
an MPC next time when he woke up and he
talked to him and he recognized a
dialogue from his other playthrough that
was a character from later in the game
that gives he's a quest giver and he was
there next to his character right the
beginning and should not have been there
and he gave him the quest complete
dialogue from like four hours later yeah
what that sounds whoo yeah and then I we
John Luke again was Captain some stuff
and he was talking to us a conversation
happening with through the wall and
whatever that object is yes he was
talking about if you're if you're
wondering why we're showing boring
footage like this that's because this is
what we saw when we were playing uh you
know you fight the cat here and this is
like I said please do some funny videos
and there are gifts and whatnot of like
peavy the asari character holding her
gone the wrong way hey PB and there are
other problems this game and again we'll
get into those here are the two tracks
right here I'm just kind of hanging out
he just spontaneous clone busting
happened and now here he is both of his
versions talking to him but oh man I got
off track because of this footage we can
use more of this in a little bit um but
I want to talk about other triple-a
games with roughly releases the first
one that comes to mind that was pretty
broken was Assassin's Creed unity do you
guys remember that when it released oh
yeah did you play it no no I I played it
like when I was twenty dollars later
down the line yeah it's just like even
then it was still broking and it was
just wasn't a very good game too so this
was when I was kind of falling off the
assassins creed train you lasted a long
time well because I longer than most
yeah cuz a black flag was one right
before this correct for ya yeah and
oxide was like that and I really liked
black flag but not for like Assassin's
Creed purposes this game was rough when
it released it was like you sometimes
you just get quite clip into crowds and
get stuck with my half the game
say no more well definitely watch the
videos life light and this dude posing
is this is he's just imported some sort
of ice sword his bday is a fair ball guy
right with like yeah yeah I hope I don't
know if John Luke has footage you can
pull up of that horrifying face guy that
they showed up ropes he doesn't pull
that up but yeah this game I mean I
didn't really like this game outside the
bugs but this was roughing it watch and
they started subsequently repairing it
after they released but it still wasn't
that great of a game but now here we go
is gonna keep climbing nope nope try
again nope oh man yeah so the guy the
friggin face like in this lapel through
his mouth this is not a rough life but
to Ubisoft credit they did repair it in
the subsequent weeks I don't know what
state it's and now but it just didn't
really hit home at release I could watch
these all day yeah I don't know I'm
struggling not get knocked down here the
montage jeez it's like the unattended
like paralysis or whatever and like
oblivion or Skyrim and they just freeze
mage roll down a mountain go ahead the
office of rag dolling yes tumble and
over I see limb uh okay gonna try to
move on from unity possible so unity
they did uh keep some repairs to it
something like numerous patches it still
took a while but I guess they made it
better technically I dont still really
like that game but at least they you
know fixed major problems people have
that another one which is more due to
multiplayer servers in general was
battlefield 4 this is a big one because
like I don't like for me I got an xbox
one at launch and I got battlefield 4
and that was it didn't work so it's like
all right well I got this xbox one god
damn it
how you felt staring at your ass this
looks like the map the MLB Reese well
and I'll be okay very well that was MLB
to guess or Emily 17 is very very it's
still not done so don't take that but
you can look up just look up Emily 17
face click should've shared the dev
share them like they had a good sense of
humor about any early that was a that we
just saw was a release game a
battlefield 4 was just not working and
it like the campaign was will the
campaign to like I think I like it
wouldn't save my game I play like four
or five hours of it and then it would
delete my game and I'd be like okay I
guess I'll try again so I try again and
like my friends like yeah I beat it but
I just did in one sitting because it
kept happening to me as well so it's
like the game was broken yeah and I do
you member how long it took to fix I
don't know it was weeks right like I
think I played it again a couple months
after it worked but like yeah it was
probably weeks if not months yeah Aaron
Samson he's like a resident military
shooter but especially battlefield
expert and I remember him talking about
it he was saying was super disappointing
don't ever mention bad company to him
because he'll talk forever about how
good that game is but like when on the
rare occasion he talks about another
battlefield he's talked about
battlefield 4 is broken launch and I
remember when I first came to GC into
the 2013 San Francisco it was like a
massive battlefield 4 it was the
battlefield 4 reveal never just that was
like the biggest like ad they had over
at moscone convention center and then
like a few months later just the game
was destroyed that release yeah but it
did fix it took a long time did not
release in great shape um yeah I guess
good on them down the road but uh all
right destiny this is different because
this was not technically may it
massively flawed at the beginning I mean
yeah I wasn't like broken but a lot of
people had problems with vanilla destiny
and a lot of that was rectified with
taking king but um I mean you know
replacing a tinkle bot um wait whoa what
the famous line I thought that wizard
came from the moon one I don't know like
who was directing those voice acting
sessions but
uh yeah so yeah so the interesting thing
there is because it's you know a
multiplayer game and that's the main
conceit of it it's constantly evolving
so I liked that they took steps to fix
problems that weren't necessarily like
game-breaking problems but that we're
hurting people's enjoyment of a lot of
things you could do by yourself and so I
think that was an example of something
that I mean I regardless of how you feel
about destiny definitely improved over
time and so it's an example something
that like oh they fixed a lot of
dialogue problems and gave the story a
little more interest and I enjoyed
taking a lot I played all of taking yeah
mechanically destiny felt awesome right
away it still does but I also was
playing it just for the sake of it I
didn't really love it but then yeah I
like taking a lot to for the how it
changed the structure of the game yeah
and yeah and also the fact that they
were poised replaced that voice acting
and kind of wrote a whole new script for
uh it was it Troy Nolan North no one
northen yeah no one North did your ghost
and ya know they fixed it I think I
don't I didn't really like rise of iron
but maybe that was just because in you
know comparison to taken King which a
revamped destiny kind of uh paled in
comparison well yeah rise of iron wasn't
a completely new expect like it didn't
add as much as taken King did but I've
also reused a lot of assets and so all
of the the enemies and rise of iron were
just like slightly altered Reese kins mm
in the areas were reskin Xand so that's
what I didn't like about it was very
repetitive to what I'd played before in
a way that a different from how destiny
is naturally repetitive I guess um so
yeah rise my arm was like a step not
down for me but it just was like oh this
i just am happy with taking hey guys
don't play taken King sure the the raid
was good yeah uh and then in terms of
another rough launch it's very different
in because I it's very different because
I think this is based more on
pre-release marketing and what people
expected but I might be worth talking
about no man's sky hmm a game you liked
I'd like yeah yeah um but I it wasn't a
game that I was really excited for going
into it it was one where was kind of
like okay I'll review this and I'll find
something interesting to like keep
myself you know
or just to get excited about and what I
found early on was the Atlas path for me
that made the game super fulfilling and
everything around it was kind of just in
support of that which is great but I
think a lot of people were expecting
this like you know once in a while
you'll meet someone from the other side
of the universe that's been a player and
you can like share all these things and
yeah that didn't happen so I didn't
really find that terribly disappointing
but certainly a lot of people did and
hello games is you know gone to great
lengths to sort of add stuff that aspect
still it really isn't there I don't
think yeah um but I mean did you guys
play Jake you played right I put a lot
of no man's sky did you like it despite
it not having those things yeah i mean i
tempered my expectations quite a bit and
say like i know a lot of people who are
mad about or expecting like this grand
adventure with this great story and like
all these different characters you'll
meet along the way and like maybe you'll
come across a civilization instead it
was just kind of like but the act of
exploring and like especially like
taking off in your ship in like in that
sense so he does a great yeah I think
yeah and like I mean just like the idea
like the Atlas path and particularly the
fact that you're like traveling through
like dozens if not hundreds of different
solar systems with planets the size of
like I don't know how big did they say
that they were like huge planets like
it's it's quite the adventure I think
when you look at it like that I was
pretty impressive but then also you know
it seems like a lot of people who were
excited you couldn't just look at the
game at face value and I think enjoy for
what it was so yeah different from these
other examples but i think it's it's
sort of that like what do fans expect
right yes i mean like in best case
scenario like in destiny i think was a
good example like Kelly mentioned taking
king whether it was an expansion of DLC
these games kind of you know like
improved in the aftermath others that
were technically glitchy at first
obviously you know in 2017 unfortunately
a lot of games are released without the
polish that we used to expect I think
now because you can get day one patches
and whatnot or sometimes you know like
an assassin creed unity it could take a
while battlefield 4 it could take a
while but thankfully the most the ones
we just mentioned were kind of improved
in the aftermath but let us know if we
forgot any especially ones that did kind
of get fixed in subsequent weeks or
months after its
release let us know in the YouTube
comments or in the chat as we move on
with the show
[Music]